[Music]
the deep south
the antebellum is seeing a lot of
uh say social change and uh
cancel culture is uh making its rounds
down what is antebellum
antebellum like the style of the house
actually i don't know what antebellum
can we type in i just know that it
refers to the
the american south antibond antebellum
antebellum
because i heard about lady antebellum
occurring or existing before a
particular war
especially the american civil war
so it's like a time period before the
civil war yeah so that's
basically slavery era in in america
like pre-1860 yeah wait then why would
they want to
name their band lady antebellum i don't
know anyway
let's move on i don't think that we were
woke enough then when they named their
band that way
um but yeah so a lot of our country now
especially the south is seeing a lot of
uh
you know changes in terms of how we view
uh
our history and things like that and
many of which
has affected different industries
and one such industry is the wedding
industry
and uh not just corona huh yes and and
what i'm talking about is our
plantations
within the south a lot of people go to
the plantations to get married have
events and you know
a very big parties and stuff like that
and
ryan reynolds and blake lively recently
uh
released a statement saying that they
were they basically apologized for
having their wedding in south carolina
at a 330 year old plantation
so they they apologize for having a
wedding at the
boone hall plantation and gardens in
mount pleasant south carolina
was it like a cotton plantation and it's
got a lot of
bad like history there our plantations
usually like slave related
i don't know because i have a different
we're in the west coast and then
when i think of plantation i think of
pineapple plantation in hawaii
which doesn't have the same doesn't have
the same there was exploitation but
there wasn't slavery
but a lot of hawaiian culture is built
from the plantation
life like that's where a lot of like
you know japanese chinese a lot of
filipinos like mixed and then like the
local hawaiian culture is built
from the plantation lifestyle and so i
don't know like
because i'm not from the south like i
don't think when i hear the word
plantation it doesn't
feel negative oh interesting yeah it was
growing up in texas
like when i hear the word plantation i
automatically think negative slavery
like that's like the first thing that
comes to my mind yeah so it's really
hard to kind of
shake that imagery away from these types
of establishments and as beautiful as
they are
they have uh you know a very violent and
oppressive history
and so so is it like if you visit a
plantation you kind of
it feels like heavy like when you visit
like a concentration you went to one we
visited one in new orleans yeah oak
alley yeah and it feels like heavy when
you go there
yeah because like they keep everything
there so it's like aside from aside from
hosting weddings and parties and events
they also have like you know history
tours they actually have like the homes
that they lived in like slaves lived in
yeah so they have these little huts
outside of the main building
and so it's like having a wedding at the
holocaust museum
yes exactly it's weird yeah that's what
they're basically saying it's like
you know like you're holding your own
wedding at a place where
people were oppressed and like killed
and and tortured
doesn't seem right you know yeah and
it's also different that it's still
like for the one that you were saying
like they still like they have
tours so they have all of the old stuff
so it's like right in front of your face
because i was picturing like a vineyard
like you know how out here in in norcal
they have wineries and people get
married there so that it's a beautiful
romantic
place right but then i'm thinking okay i
don't know what a cotton plantation
looks like
but it doesn't sound like a nice wedding
location
maybe it's like really like country
rustic you know pinterest
world oh yeah yeah yeah what it is i see
the building where the whites live
that building is is going to be
beautiful and very our
artistry like the the orange the the
architecture
architecture
yeah the craftsmanship of the homes like
it's beautiful and so i think a lot of
people pick these places
i just they get wedded there i found
partner of mushroom farm
so then i recently visited the mushroom
bar farm right
and i'm like why the [ __ ] would anybody
want to get married here wait people
actually get married at the moment no
but i'm saying like oh
an operation like a farm like it's
it's pretty dirty like why the [ __ ]
would anyone want to get married
it smells like manure and [ __ ] it
matches the aesthetic that's why
sorry i was just gonna say who's who's
profiting from
these plantations being used for like
these tours and for
educational purposes well sometimes it's
like historic historic reason like
historic preservation so like when we
went it's like
i don't know for a fact i forgot but but
no like it ends up being
part of history of that area so then the
historical society
or whatever it is like they end up being
the ones that are running
the tours or whatever it is who's making
money from the weddings though because
that in itself could present the issue
yeah where does it go yeah like it could
be like the city or it could be
privately owned
true yeah i mean they just refer to it
as a preserved estate so
uh maybe it's owned by a certain family
i don't know the same family
the same family yeah just been passed
down through these now what you're
saying is that's
the new i guess big shift where it was
pretty commonplace for people to get
married
in the south at a plantation home and
then now that's like no longer
right now it's kind of frowned upon and
even like a lot of the wedding magazines
the wedding magazines have also kind of
expressed
their like boycott of this uh this
tradition now
and so like they're not they're no
longer including these
plantations in their magazines they're
no longer pinterest is also
cutting ties a lot of plantations
they're no longer exhibiting them in
their in their
pictures so yeah there's a big shift in
that industry down there
it's kind of got a tainted history
doesn't it like why would
well i don't know i guess they're
accepting it but i don't know if i'm
i'm i'm imagining like these places to
being like a museum and then you see
like
all of the things that they used back
then like
are they hiding all of the stuff that
they used for slavery and all that too
or because i don't know i've never been
into one but when i'm thinking of how
they preserve like
anywhere you go to right like if you go
to like a gold rush cabin
you'll see like yeah they did it like
this or like
even if you go to [ __ ] um medieval
times right you'll see like the torture
things and [ __ ] yeah yeah it's all like
wow that's just [ __ ] up
yeah i don't remember seeing torture i
do remember seeing like
chains oh man yeah you see like the
little huts that they lived in
and like and then they lay out clothes
that they wore and it's like
[ __ ] up clothing it's like it's coarse
you know it doesn't it's like a potato
sack and [ __ ]
literally a tail sack that has legs you
know and like re-sewn to have legs
that's mind-blowing they have weddings
that this kind of yeah that's
wild when we went because we had isaac
with that like our son
and we were just like trying to like
educate him like do you see
this is part of our history like
actually this happened
and because they were we were reading
because they actually gave a lot of
information so you can educate yourself
about what went on in that plantation
obviously they're going to make it more
like fluffy because yeah
they want to make themselves look good
but well yeah it is pretty heavy
for sure yeah and so then the the uh
this boon
uh what were they growing there tobacco
cotton i really don't remember it was so
long ago
yeah this boone hall plantation has
released a statement too and they
basically said that they treasure
all couples that have ever wetted there
and their relationships and that if
anyone feels
uh you know have any concerns about you
know having their wedding there
they're they're open to open a line of
dialogue and and talk to these couples
and kind of
you know just i guess nurture like
everyone's emotions and and kind of
figure out how to move forward
but there isn't like a whole lot of like
i guess direction in terms of what
they're going to do
to i guess change the way they conduct
their business well they can't really
do it i mean it's history it's just like
i don't know
yeah how do you really re-brand it
because they were all
work camps you know they're not
like every i feel like industry has
some kind of tainted like there was
child labor like in the industrial
revolution there was like
now i mean even now they exploit migrant
workers and in farms and stuff right
but slavery's just a whole different
story it's it was
really [ __ ] up and there was torture
and all that stuff
and those work camps are like prisoner
work camps and that's
that's such a heavy ass tainted thing
like how do you even clean that
up i think the way to clean it up is you
knock it all down
i mean if you want to if you want to use
it for a place
of of happiness and [ __ ] long lasting
memories of you [ __ ] tying the knot
you know if that's how you want to use
it then wipe it all out but if
you're using it as a museum then you
just leave it alone just don't have a
[ __ ]
festive party there that's weird it's
true yeah i'm actually
kind of uh happy that at least it hasn't
gotten to the point where they're
thinking about demolishing these types
of things because you know the statues
are being torn down and all that but
like
you know there's a part of it that's
also kind of like the history it's there
for us to remember
and kind of like it's i guess it's kind
of reflecting yeah reflecting on our
history it's just
weird to mix those feelings that is
weird like let's let's say we go to a
pearl harbor memorial and we have a
wedding there
it's weird it says it's so somber like
you just feel the energy in the air you
know but i think that it
is weird this it makes sense why because
on a plantation there's a lot of
different memories like
it was the privileged memories there was
yeah the the memories of the
of the white people were different from
the memories of the black people there
so like that's true
that's probably what it is you know but
we've also come a long way from
that time where now the memories of the
black people are
something that everyone should be
thinking about yeah that's what i was
gonna say i'm like
if you're gonna be or okay so
yeah there are different memories being
made right and just like in a
concentration camp obviously the
the victims have different memories than
the guards or whatever but you're still
respecting
what happened there and you're not going
to be
celebrating weddings there because of
what had happened there
so yeah i don't i don't think having
weddings at a plantation just does not
seem like it's a good idea it's just
really weird
that's true it's so [ __ ] weird i feel
like that's really the only thing that's
wrong with this picture here is that
they're allowing
for weddings to occur at this area yeah
i think it's great that they're still
doing like historical type educational
yeah that's important that's really
important let's go with that because if
we forget it
it only opens the space of like future
hatred and things like that we need to
remember this as yeah not repeat
that's why like graphic that's why like
movies are so effective and
making us feel certain ways about like
mass genocide it's one thing to
read about in a textbook and be like all
these people that sucks you know but
then when you see it for yourself like
maybe not for yourself but when you see
it like
on a screen and it's very vivid and it's
very graphic and you see these people
suffering
that makes you feel a completely
different way except if they suck at
acting and it's like a bad action movie
and people are dying like oh
oh oh and you just laugh at it right
but if it's really good then you're just
like oh i felt that dude that was
that was good acting right there and
then you believe it yeah so
ryan reynolds uh has released uh an
instagram post
stating you know sorry i had a wedding
there yeah his like it was a mistake and
he was blind to
you know like the history and you know
he's it's a very heartfelt message
so i don't think asians have gone
through anything that bad in america
of course so our equivalent is way less
but to me it's like
where did i get tortured at like a
tutoring center so it'd be like me
getting married at a tutor
like why would any asians want to go
back to get married at a tuning
attendant
and it was asian on asian crime yeah i
got my ass b and did extra homework
get married at chinese school exactly
yeah who wants to get married at chinese
school guys
nerds
[Music]
so
you